[Music]
all right
in utah news
utah news oh yeah we haven't done that
forever utah looks beautiful shout out
to utah
utah is a beautiful state they have a
lot of lavender farms
minus the whole like uh the the teen
industry thing right now that paris
hilton is fighting the provo kenyan
stuff where was that when is that part
about youtube
i don't even know about that what is
that the troubled teen industry that
she's fighting against because that's
where she went
when she was a teen remember last time
we talked about horse and i didn't see i
didn't see the documentary back then but
now i saw it
and that's what she's fighting against
and like utah has these loophole laws
that allow these facilities to
[ __ ] abuse kids oh no i did not i did
not know what's it called again
provo canyon provo canyon is that a
place provo utah
provo utah but provo canyon is like one
of the facilities that do this [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] that's nice [ __ ] provo canyon
dude
utah's tainted for me now because of
that reason because of the loophole
but do you follow patterson homes they
got some beautiful houses
shout out to patterson homes and nothing
against the people in shout out episode
all i know is that the mormons
bankrolled a lot of las vegas casinos oh
[ __ ] yeah shout out to them
good morning apartments dude and vegas
good for you guys
i'll do it without you all right so in
draper utah
a corner canyon high school wait what's
that
say
we thought you said draper without the d
so that's why me and joe went
well that's a scary name it's very easy
to miss one literally
that name yeah drake bird utah
high school was opening and they were
trying to figure out
what their mascot was going to be they
leave it up to a vote
they left it up for a vote by the
student body wait they didn't pick this
beforehand like back in the 1950s
no brand new school being built yeah
yeah oh yeah
brand new school being built uh shout
outs to patterson schools
draper uh so yeah so the colors were
gonna be navy silver and white is what
they
those are dope colors decided on and um
they left the student body to just to
decide on what the mascot was going to
be
so is it a giant snowflake no yeah
actually yeah that was one of the
choices
they had a choice of uh chargers
diamondbacks
falcons raptors broncos what
bears
huh which one would you guys have gone a
hot old woman they all sound pretty good
they're normal
they all sound like the same to me yeah
i thought it was gonna be some crazy
like
new age [ __ ] that you're like the
snowflakes [ __ ] corner canyon
kombuchas or something
the kombuchas oh that's good i like that
nothing stronger than a probiotic
five billion of them oh yeah we'll crush
the competition
with my probiotics all right so the
school decided
uh that chargers was gonna be the winner
all right like phone charger what is a
charger
charger yeah phone charger what is the
context of a truck
charge like like sending it like the san
diego charger
yes yes yes what is the charger oh i
never questioned that like a
zap electricity yeah it's like a
lightning bolt okay that's the logo
really yeah i didn't know that
that makes yeah yeah that's one of those
i forgot true phillip rivers is the
mascot electronics huh
here is where the story gets interesting
uh-oh because chargers was not
the choice the students picked what did
they pick that one
it was cougars okay i liked cool decided
not to go cougars because of joe's
reason and what was your reason why
old women hot old women they decided
that cougars may be offensive to
middle-aged
women like the teachers there or
something
i thought cougars are a good animal yeah
it's a [ __ ] animal it's an animal and
it's also
slang you can't base the decision off
what it
means on the streets and it's also like
the cougar association of utah was
pretty upset about this yeah all these
hot old ladies were like yo
yo yo yo na you think cougars like
actual cougars that are trying to have
sex with younger men you think they give
a [ __ ] about what
a school they don't want to be
associated with youth and young age
they're cool they're not high schoolers
though not high schoolers unless they
found out
they found out the intention of these
students and they were like oh yeah we
could be the cougars
and then they were like no you're not
you're not getting or what if it was the
design of the mascot
was a uh old lady a cigarette out of her
neck wait that's not a cougar that's not
a cook
what's a cougar in your mind then
explain cougars he's like i would love
to have cougars of milf
super hot milf with a really big problem
no
that's a really big problem bart's
open-minded
i mean if i was the graphic designer at
this school that's sort of what i would
have submitted and that would have
totally
like passed you know did you guys see
the video of that guy hiking and he was
getting chased by the cougar
yeah that looks scary that [ __ ] was
crazy he's getting chased by this cougar
for like five minutes i want to see
he walks by he sees the cub and then
like a couple minutes later
the mom comes out and like stares him
down the way she was like
chasing is like just runs at him he's
like no no
stay back no and he's freaking out he's
like [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you and he's
like throwing rocks at it dude
it's it's intense so he had time to grab
rocks and throw it
can we see can we see what the [ __ ]
that's a little that's a little cub so
cute though right did he say oh come
here cute
oh [ __ ] oh whoa where where where where
why wait wait for it wait for it but the
club running or the mom
[ __ ] you where the mom
why is he not recording it well it's in
the bushes it comes out
by protecting his life fear of his life
this is like jurassic park oh my god
he was all good dude that's beautiful
where does he live
[ __ ] yeah where where is his hat
he's roaring back at it it was in the
bushes hiding
would it what if he chased it what if he
went straight to it apparently that's
what we're supposed to do just to get
big and like
be menacing be dominant
[Music]
do it
[Music]
this cougar is chasing him for so long
the terrain changes
but what about the baby though i know
she's just abandoned the baby
baby dude that's giving me chills dude
go away i'm big and scary i'm bigger i
like this
it's creating distance though dude it
gets close
really it gets closer can we fast
forward a little bit yeah can you
imagine walking backward like that a run
and what if she chases you dude yeah
you're not apparently you're not
supposed to turn your back
if you turn back they're gonna [ __ ] you
up yeah so you have to be facing it you
feel big because it registers
yeah i fought many cougars in my day so
like i know so like this is what you're
supposed to do
is this the same kind of cuckoo that you
fought it's the wonder tricky out of me
[Laughter]
that one got him i got that cougars
you're not getting me dude my dumb ass
would have started running
i think i was too yeah give me your best
roar if this cougar was
oh cheating
oh [ __ ] my kid
it's been 15 minutes oh she's
one clip though you saw the whole thing
no i didn't see the whole thing i just
saw this small clip on twitter though
yeah it jumps up and it's like this it's
doing that oh my god
like on its hind legs yeah oh yeah right
here
i found it i found it yeah because i
remember seeing the thumb what made that
cougar run like
did he grab a rock and toss it or i
don't know i would be scared to grab a
rock
oh my god oh i would
[ __ ] my pants holy [ __ ]
this dude's pants is already sold dude
[ __ ] you dude i don't even blame him if
he shot his pants here
for real he comes back oh my god
[Music]
this guy's brave as [ __ ] yeah this guy
held his composure really well
i might and then at the end of the video
he's like dude
what state was that uh you're talking i
don't know you talk
you talk
so shout out to utah and all the jokers
you top people love
cougars bro that's that's all it is just
gotta accept it and let them name the
school the cougars
back to the school though so they ended
up naming them what chargers
and then like like how cougars charged
there's nothing wrong with charges
though right like there's no like other
charm that could be you
can be like confused for or something
well if you take offense to apple taking
away the chargers
and the new to the new packaging then
maybe that could be offensive gonna buy
it separately yeah now they're
making a bunch what a bunch of jerks i
know and people are still gonna buy it
too have you seen a difference between a
mountain lion and a cougar
no cougar looks like a cat and a
mountain lion looks like a kitty cat
really i thought mountain lions were
bigger i thought yeah mountain lions
would be beefier like
buffer yeah because i remember there was
always something in the news in the
summer where mountain lions would attack
a hiker here
in l.a we have a lot of mountain lions
in our uh mountain ranges i've never
really seen one you took us hiking there
dude i did man we
almost got eaten by a mountain lion this
guy
he took us yeah but yeah so the kids
trying to make a bottle video man
it's good content so the kids who voted
for
the cougars for this uh high school
mascot probably weren't thinking about
cougars as in like sexy old women or
middle-aged women sorry
not yet uh not yet but utah's biggest
college which is brigham
young university their mascot happens to
be
a cougar so they're just thinking oh
that the high school kids the local kids
here just want to have
the cougar because it's also kind of
synonymous with the state's
university you know so that's probably
what's wrong with that
from cooper to cougar don't even give
the kids
a choice yeah if you're not gonna let
them choose yeah
and also don't actually publicly say
that that's your reason why you're not
gonna pick cougar because you think you
sound ridiculous you literally wrote an
article about how the fact that that's
what they wanted there
that makes me go like oh my kid goes to
school i'm pulling them out out of the
school
that's so stupid that was their intent
to make their mascot
the cougars because oh yeah hot older
ladies
it's still gonna be the animal the
cougar anyway
right what difference does it make very
true you're gonna dress the cougar
in women's clothing or like what yeah
like what the [ __ ] yeah they make it a
point that there's a lot of
uh sports teams currently uh both
professional and on the collegiate level
that have
cougar as their their mascot so it's
kind of like
what's the big deal you know what the
obviously these teams were created
before the term cougar became a term for
uh for middle-aged women so i don't know
people are [ __ ] out of their minds
[Music]
you